- Do you have a secret talent?
- Yeah, I can sing any song in key,
but as, like a small hamster.
- Hey, it's Sam Stryker with Buzzfeed
at the iHeartRadio Music
Awards in Hollywood.
We're gonna talk to celebrities
about their hidden talents.
- I can pop my thumbs.
It's kinda nasty, but.
- That's pretty awesome.
- Yeah, let's do it.
- Just gotta loosen the knee up.
- Whoa!
Wow, the stank is real.
Important question.
- Yeah.
- Hidden talents, do you have any?
- Yes.
- Can we see a hidden talent?
- Nah, hidden talents
are bedroom things, man,
hidden talents, no I'm just
playing, I'm just playing.
- I can cross one eye.
- Can we see it?
- Yeah, ready?
- [Sam] Wow.
- That's talent.
- That's amazing, that's
memeable right there.
- Right, that's gonna be a meme.
- Why do I say to you,
at the iHeart Awards,
my boy Jordan and me, are gonna go sit,
and enjoy the show.
That's about as good as I can do.
- Look at this thing with my tongue.
- That's pretty legit.
- Oh, goodness, I can rap the
entire soundtrack of Hamilton.
- Can you give us a taste?
Oh, okay, um, ten dolla, founding father
without a father, gotta
lot farther by working
a lot harder, by being a lot smarter,
by being a self-starter, by fourteen,
they placed him in charge
of a trading charter--
- Okay, so I'm double-jointed.
- Can we see?
- It's kinda gross.
- Now we really wanna see.
- No, okay so, I'm hyperextended,
so look, normal arm, oh wait! (laughs)
- Well crap, we'll edit that out.
- Can I do Adele?
- I was gonna say Hello,
so, we've got ESPN.
- (clears throat)
Hello from the other side,
I must have called a thousand times,
to tell you I'm sorry,
for breaking your heart.
- I can levitate.
- Really?
- [Hozier] Yes.
- Can you levitate for us now?
- Only at parties.
- Okay, okay.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- That was amazing.
- Right, like right on cue.
- You might have a second career
doing Kia commercials down the road.
- Oh my god, I'm gonna
be like the fat hamsters.
- (laughs) That'd be amazing.